اي شخص يهتم بالتاريخ وكثير ما تصلني يعني
اسئله وكده انه انت غارق في التاريخ انت
غارق في الماضي انت تبكي على الاطلال
واتفهم هذه الاسئله لكن دعني اوضح لك مثال
على اهميه العنايه بالتاريخ والاهتمام
بالتاريخ هناك مجموعه او او نمط من
الباحثين والاكاديميين في الجامعات
العالميه هؤلاء وظيفتهم ان يتنباوا باحداث
المستقبل كيف تنباوا باحداث المستقبل
هؤلاء المتخصصون في التاريخ هم يعرفون
ويتنبؤون احداث المستقبل من خلال دراسه
التاريخ فهم لدينا حاله معاصره اليوم لا
نفهم كثير من جوانبها وابعادها او ما الذي
سيحدث بعد ذلك يقوم هؤلاء المختصون في
الماضي بدراسه الحالات الشبيهه بها ثم
بالسيناريوهات بالظبط كلنا بنسبه كذا وكذا
سوف يحدث التالي هذا هذا اثر عظيم للعنايه
في التاريخ امر اخر مهم يا استاذ خالد في
موضوع مساله العنايه بالتاريخ وبعيدا عن
ازماتنا الثقافيه والسجالاتنا الدينيه
والع
امر مهم اننا حينما نفهم التاريخ فان هذا
هو بمثابه مفتاح لفهم انفسنا لفهم ذواتنا
لماذا لاننا نحن عباره عن ايش انا وانتم
الجميع من حولنا عباره عن تشكل تاريخي
تشكل ثقافي
مبادئنا ثقافاتنا قيمنا تقاليدنا عاداتنا
ادابنا فنوننا خيالاتنا حتى الامثال التي
نستخدمها هي تراكم جاء من التاريخ فلما
افهم التاريخ هذا سيساعدني بشكل كبير جدا
اذا فهم نفسي كيف تشكلت شخصيتي وكيف تشكلت
هويتي